la cuarta ola de la pandemia de
coronavirus está golpeando a alemania de
manera muy dramática con cifras récord
de infectados con cada vez más distritos
en crisis y con creciente preocupación
por lo que todo esto pueda significar no
solamente para las hospitalizaciones
sino también a medida que se acercan los
meses de invierno que en el pasado
demostraron ser muy difíciles para
controlar las infecciones no ayuda que
actualmente alemania esté en un limbo
político sin un gobierno claro tras las
elecciones federales de septiembre y
tampoco ayuda a que las vacunaciones no
estén avanzando con la rapidez con la
que quisieran las autoridades ya se
están discutiendo posibles medidas a
nivel nacional y los primeros estados
federados ya anunciaron también sus
propias medidas las autoridades aquí en
alemania están mirando con detenimiento
también lo que ocurre en algunos países
vecinos donde la situación también es
muy seria
austria por ejemplo anunció nuevas
restricciones en particular para los no
vacunados mientras dinamarca en el norte
se vio forzada a anunciar también
restricciones dos meses después de haber
retirado